hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Gerry today
you were checking out the trailer for a
film I think it's a horror movie called
Circle our killer I'm checking this out
because I was asked to open the film at
copy that it's gonna be premiering at
Comic Con I'm gonna be doing the opening
for it so I'm like delayed on reactions
or whatever it's because I'm there cuz
you're at San Diego Comic thinks can
exactly
I'm gonna be opening this film I'm doing
then posting the QA afterwards too but I
don't know what the [ __ ] this movie is
let's let's let's see what this movie's
actually about
sir
hello
hello whoa
ah they can see us I don't know
are we where you think
the Carter
okay now they're killing us oh no it's
not them are you guys seen this look at
your hands when you move them it changes
the floor it's a vote they're killing
whoever gets the most alert it's us
we're choosing who dies
what do you think happens when we get
down to the last person that person gets
transferred to cube or cube to hybrids
bud dope boom okay
Wow I kinda remind me of like saw five
yeah six six well
parts of five six yeah little bit of a
saw in there basically not like your
Tesla but also like devil in a way well
yeah I mean it's that psychological
thing of like you know you're trapped in
this situation and now like instinct or
or just you you're gonna find out who
people really are through this very
intense situation and that is a scary
psychology
I got a concern and I got a compliment
okay all right compliment I like the
concept of them while being in the
circle and then voting for who gets to
die I hope it's done in a fashion where
I'm in the audience going like hmm maybe
this person should die well if they're
having like a discussion argument voting
for like I want to be part of the debate
myself
yeah it's that that dark psychology
thing that you get to then participate
exactly my worry my concern is that the
acting doesn't look the best so it makes
me go will I really care enough about
this or will I want everyone to just die
okay you know but the acting it's just a
trailer and I don't like to judge the
performance is too much based off of a
trailer yeah and Grant and I'm doing the
QA so I bet a lot of this cast will be
there so hope you guys are watching this
video right now it looks kind of like a
clever way to do a very low-budget
thriller you know is yes like you've
created enough intrigue with this black
room with just these lights on the floor
Tomika I even as I don't know why but I
kind of got a young adult
live in the way of how you got like a
bunch of strangers and they kind of have
to it's about like survival yeah it
looks cool I like the ply I feel like
this could be really interesting I
wonder what the runtime of it is does it
feel like a good 90 minutes with you 164
minutes like a two-hour 40 minutes
everyone gets their own monologue yeah
it's gonna be so intense we're gonna get
to know every character intimately
I wonder how it'll be shot like all of
it you know cuz that is a challenge to
shoot but if they were able to pull off
movies like berry devil I'm sure they
could pull this off - mm-hmm Jonnie in
the middle my monolith yeah film looks
pretty good I'd like to see it there's a
lot of good indie horror flicks out
there this kind of even has a sci-fi
element in a way it's not like obvious
but I feel it and something about it
feels like science fiction yeah you know
anyway guys thanks for tuning in what I
also wanted to say was this sentence
here like I said this movie will be
showing at comic-con you can RSVP to go
to the screening at circle on screening
circle constant circle circle con
screening at gmail.com yeah you can RSVP
RSVP a ticket it's gonna be down San
Diego of course and I'll be there so if
you guys want to hang out let me know
oh as ba ronica will be there with me
too
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out Jerry's playlist on
this channel reasons to Jerry and dank
ass Stubbs you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine you know what
this movie would have been a better
circle movie about if everyone was doing
a circle jerk that way you can direct
the porno yeah
circle jerk we vote for who gets the
jerk off or you know whoever comes first
is the first person to vote last when
they come lives